maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa Quantum na impormasyon at computation ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous at ako ang teknikal na direktor para sa edukasyon sa IBM
Quantum ito ang ika-10 aralin ng serye at ito ang ikalawang aralin sa ikatlong yunit na tungkol sa pangkalahatang
pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon ang araling ito ay tungkol sa mga channel na kumakatawan sa mga pagbabago sa
mga sistema na nag-iimbak ng Quantum na impormasyon kasama rito ang mga kapaki-pakinabang na operasyon tulad ng mga isinasagawa ng
mga unitary Gates at Quantum circuits pati na rin ang mga pagbabagong maaaring gusto nating iwasan tulad ng ingay maaari rin nating ilarawan ang mga sukat
bilang mga channel at iyon ang tatalakayin natin sa susunod na aralin ang terminong channel ay nagmula sa atin mula sa
information Theory na bukod sa iba pang bagay ay pinag-aaralan ang kapasidad ng pagdadala ng impormasyon ng maingay na komunikasyon
mga channel kaya kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa mga channel nag-iisip tayo nang abstract tungkol sa komunikasyon
mga channel maaaring mukhang kakaiba ang pag-iisip tungkol sa isang kumplikadong computation bilang isang communication Channel ngunit kailangan natin ng isang
salita upang tumukoy sa pangkalahatang konsepto ng isang prosesong nagbabago ng impormasyon sa ilang paraan at sa mabuti man o masamang kapalaran ang salitang
channel ay nanatili walang alinlangan na malaking bahagi nito ay dahil sa napakalaking epekto ng information Theory at partikular na ng
gawa ni Claude Shannon noong 1940s sa Quantum na impormasyon at computation narito ang isang pangkalahatang-ideya ng
aralin magsisimula tayo sa mga pangunahing kaalaman kabilang ang kahulugan ng channel pati na rin kung paano maaaring ilarawan ang mga unitary na operasyon sa pinasimpleng pormulasyon
ng quantum na impormasyon bilang mga channel pag-uusapan din natin ang katotohanan na ang mga convex combination ng mga channel ay mga channel at kung ikaw ay
nagtataka kung bakit ang konsepto ng convexity ay patuloy na lumalabas ito ay dahil tunay itong isang mahalagang pangunahing konsepto sa matematika sa teorya ng
quantum na impormasyon makikita rin natin ang ilang halimbawa ng mga channel partikular na ang mga Cubit channel na muling lalabas sa iba't ibang pagkakataon
sa natitirang bahagi ng aralin sa ikalawang bahagi ng aralin pag-uusapan natin ang tatlong magkakaibang paraan na maaari nating katawanin ang mga channel
sa matematika at partikular na pag-uusapan natin ang mga Stinespring representation Krauss representation at Choi
representation na pinangalanan sa tatlong tao na ang gawa ay mahalaga sa pagpapaunlad ng iba't ibang representasyong ito at sa ikatlo at
huling bahagi ng aralin tatalakayin natin ang isang patunay sa matematika na nagtatatag na ang tatlong representasyong ito ay katumbas nga pati na rin ang katotohanan na sila
lahat ay wastong nagpapakilala sa kahulugan ng channel ito ay isang talagang magandang patunay sa matematika sa aking opinyon at sana ay magdaragdag ito ng ilang
linaw sa iba't ibang presentasyong ito kung paano sila nauugnay at kung paano sila gumagana sa pangkalahatan magsisimula tayo sa mga pangunahing kaalaman at
tutukuyin ang tanong na ano ang mga channel tulad ng iminumungkahi ko na sa simula ng aralin ang mga channel ay naglalarawan ng mga pagbabago
partikular na mga discrete na pagbabago sa oras sa mga sistema na nag-iimbak ng Quantum na impormasyon dito kapag tinutukoy natin ang isang discrete na pagbabago sa oras
nag-iisip lang tayo tungkol sa isang pagbabagong nagaganap sa pagitan ng dalawang natatanging sandali sa oras kumpara sa isang
tuluy-tuloy na proseso halimbawa na may katuturang pag-isipan sa infinitesimally maliit na mga panahon ng oras ang mga channel ay may kasamang mga kapaki-pakinabang na operasyon tulad ng
mga unitary na operasyon na isinasagawa ng Quantum Gates at circuits pati na rin ang mga pagbabago dahil sa ingay halimbawa para sa
mga layunin ng araling ito bagaman pangunahin kaming mag-iisip tungkol sa mga channel sa abstract na termino ng matematika at walang partikular na pangangailangan
na makilala ang kung ano ang kapaki-pakinabang at kung ano ang hindi ang mga tipikal na pangalan para sa mga channel ay ang malalaking titik ng Griyego na fi
Sai at Omega at gagamit tayo ng iba't ibang titik upang tumukoy sa ilang partikular na channel sa isang simpleng sitwasyon kung saan
mayroon tayong ilang sistema na nasa isang estado na inilalarawan ng ilang density Matrix row at nag-aaplay tayo ng channel f sa sistemang iyon ang
resulta ay isang sistema na ang estado ay inilalarawan ng density Matrix na fi ng row kaya nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa isang ibinigay na
Channel na fi bilang isang function na maaaring ilapat sa mga density matrix ng isang partikular na laki o sa ibang salita
mga density matrix ng isang partikular na sistema na inilalapat natin ang channel na ito mayroong ilang mga kinakailangan na dapat matugunan ng mga channel upang maging
itinuturing na mga wastong channel Una ang mga channel ay mga linear na pagmamapa ito ay ganap na kahalintulad sa sitwasyon na mayroon tayo sa parehong
pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon kung saan ang mga operasyon sa mga Quantum State vector ay kinakailangang linear tulad ng
pati na rin sa karaniwang pormulasyon ng klasikal na impormasyon kung saan ang mga probabilistikong operasyon ay linear maaari kang pumili na tanungin ang pangunahing
kinakailangan ng linearidad kung talagang gusto mo ngunit kung gusto natin ng isang teoryang pare-pareho sa parehong probability Theory
at ang pagpili na katawanin ang mga Quantum state gamit ang mga density matrix kung gayon wala talaga tayong pagpipilian at kailangan lang nating tanggapin na ang mga channel ay linear
ang ikalawang kinakailangan ay ang mga channel ay nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix ito ay ganap na may katuturan dahil kung pinili nating katawanin ang
mga estado ng mga sistema gamit ang mga density matrix at nag-aaplay tayo ng channel sa isang sistema na nasa ilang estado ang resulta ay dapat na isang wastong estado at samakatuwid
kinakatawan ng isang density Matrix may isang napakahalagang punto na idadagdag dito at iyon ay ang kinakailangang ito
ay dapat na totoo hindi lamang kung nag-aaplay tayo ng channel sa isang nakahiwalay na sistema na ang estado ay inilalarawan ng isang density Matrix
kundi pati na rin kung mayroon tayong compound na sistema na ang estado ay inilalarawan ng ilang density Matrix at inilalapat natin ang channel sa
bahagi lamang ng sistemang iyon kaya iyon ang mga kinakailangan na inilalagay natin sa mga channel at makikita natin na sila ay
kahalintulad sa mga kinakailangan na mayroon tayo para sa mga operasyon sa parehong pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon at sa karaniwang pormulasyon
ng klasikal na impormasyon sa pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon ang mga operasyon ay kinakatawan ng mga unitary matrix dahil sila
ay eksaktong tumutugma sa mga linear na Mapa na palaging nagbabago ng mga Quantum State vector sa mga Quantum State vector para sa isang
ibinigay na sistema at katulad nito ang mga probabilistikong operasyon ay kinakatawan ng mga stochastic matrix dahil iyon ang mga
palaging nagbabago ng mga probability vector sa mga probability vector dito nagtatrabaho tayo sa mga density matrix at mayroong
karagdagang kinakailangan tungkol sa mga compound na sistema na lumabas na hindi kinakailangan para sa mga Quantum State vector
o mga probability vector ngunit kung hindi man ay ang mga kinakailangan ay kahalintulad at sa ilang kahulugan ay pinipilit sa atin ng pagpili
na katawanin ang mga Quantum state gamit ang mga density matrix narito ang ilang karagdagang detalye tungkol sa mga channel kabilang ang isang kombensyon
para sa kung paano natin iisipin ang input at output na sistema ng isang channel sa buong aralin pati na rin ang ilang karagdagang detalye
tungkol sa kinakailangan na ang mga channel ay palaging nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix una bawat channel ay
ipinapalagay na may isang input na sistema at isang output na sistema maaari nating pangalanan ang mga sistemang ito kung paano natin gusto ngunit sa buong
aralin gagamitin ko ang pangalang X upang tumukoy sa input na sistema at ang pangalang Y upang tumukoy sa output na sistema sa konceptong pagsasalita ang channel
ay nagbabago ng input na sistema sa output na sistema kaya ang input at output na sistema ay hindi kailanman sabay-sabay na magkasamang umiiral tayo
ay nagsisimula sa X ang channel ay inilalapat o isinasagawa at ang resulta ay ang X ay nabago na sa Y na ang estado ay
tinutukoy ng linear na pagmamapa na nauugnay sa channel ang input at output na sistema para sa isang channel ay hindi kailangang pareho at partikular na
hindi nila kailangang magkaroon ng parehong bilang ng mga klasikal na estado gayunpaman maaaring ang input at output na sistema ay talagang parehong sistema o sa ibang
salita x ay katumbas ng y kung saan nag-iisip lang tayo na ang fi ay nagbabago ng estado ng sistema at ito nga
ay madalas na sitwasyon na pinaka-interesado tayo ngunit ang posibilidad na ito ay pare-pareho sa unang bullet point sa kahulugan na hindi tayo kailanman magkaroon ng
input at output na sistema na umiiral bilang dalawang magkakahiwalay na sistema sa parehong oras at sa anumang kaso ito ay magiging maginhawa para sa
mga layunin ng araling ito na gumamit ng iba't ibang titik katulad ng X at Y upang tumukoy sa input at output na sistema
para matulungan tayong mapanatiling maayos ang mga bagay ngayon pumunta tayo sa kaunting karagdagang detalye tungkol sa kinakailangan na ang mga channel ay palaging nagbabago ng density
mga matrix sa mga density matrix ipagpalagay nating nagpapakilala tayo ng bagong sistema Z sa larawan ipagpalagay
nating bibigyan natin ng pangalang gamma ang classical State set ng bagong sistemang ito isipin ngayon na bumubuo tayo ng bagong compound na sistema ZX
na binubuo ng bagong sistema kasama ang input na sistema X ng isang channel fi at ipagpalagay na ang compound na sistemang ito ay
nasa isang estado na inilalarawan ng isang density Matrix row maaari itong maging isang arbitrary na Quantum state ng pares na ito ngunit anuman ang estado nito
palagi itong posible na ipahayag ang density Matrix Row sa porma na ipinapakita sa screen kung saan parehong A at B
ay sumasaklaw sa classical State set na gamma at bawat row AB ay isang Matrix na ang mga row at column ay tumutugma sa anumang
classical State set ng X at hindi natin kailangang bigyan ng pangalan ang classical State set na iyon sa puntong ito para maging malinaw ang bawat row AB ay hindi kinakailangang isang
density Matrix nang mag-isa ngunit ang buong Matrix row ay kinakailangang isang density Matrix kapag inilapat natin ang channel 5 sa
sistema X ito ay nababago sa Y at kaya naiwan tayo sa pares na ZY at ang paraan na tinutukoy natin ang
estado ng pares na ito pagkatapos isagawa ang fi sa X lamang ay ang pag-evaluate ng linear na pagmamapa na fi sa bawat isa sa mga matrix na row a
isa pang paraan upang sabihin ito ay ang kumuha tayo ng tensor product ng pagmamapa na fi kasama ang identity na pagmamapa sa mga square matrix na may mga row at column
na tumutugma sa gamma at iyon naman ay tumutugma sa hindi paggawa ng anuman sa bagong sistema Z ngunit ito ay katumbas na
paglalarawan at hindi ito nangangailangan ng pagpasok sa anumang mga detalye tungkol sa mga tensor product ng mga pagmamapa ng ganitong uri
gayunpaman sila ay gumagana sa isang medyo simpleng paraan na kahalintulad sa kung paano sila gumagana para sa mga vector at matrix isang paraan upang isipin ito nang biswal ay
sa mga tuntunin ng mga block matrix at kung gagawa tayo ng simplifying assumption na ang classical state set na gamma ay binubuo ng
mga integer sa pagitan ng 0 at N minus isa para sa ilang positibong integer M kung gayon magiging madaling isulat ang lahat ng ito tulad ng
ipinapakita dito ngayon at upang ulitin ang kinakailangan na inilalagay natin sa lima upang maging isang wastong Channel kailangan nating palaging makakuha ng isang density
Matrix mula sa prosesong ito at ito ay dapat na totoo anuman ang pagpipilian na ginagawa natin para sa sistema Z pati na rin ang
pagpipilian na ginagawa natin para sa row basta ito ay isang density Matrix na maaaring mukhang isang medyo mahigpit na kinakailangan at
maaari rin itong mukhang napakahirap suriin ngunit tulad ng makikita natin sa pagtatapos ng aralin ito ay hindi talaga napakahigpit
o mahirap suriin at partikular na mayroon tayong magagandang katangian sa matematika para sa kondisyong ito
na konektado sa iba't ibang representasyon na pag-uusapan natin sa bandang huli ng aralin ngayon tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa ng mga channel
simula sa isang buong kategorya ng mga channel na tinatawag na unitary channel sa simpleng termino ito ay mga unitary
na operasyon tulad ng mayroon tayo sa pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon na tiningnan bilang mga channel upang maging tiyak ipagpalagay na ang U ay isang unitary
Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang unitary na operasyon sa isang sistema X kaya sa pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum
impormasyon pararamihin natin ang Matrix na ito sa isang ibinigay na Quantum State Vector upang matukoy ang aksyon na ang operasyong iyon ay mayroon sa Quantum State na iyon ang
paraan ng paggana nito para sa mga density matrix ay ang pararamihin ang density Matrix sa kaliwa ng U at sa kanan ng U
dagger sa mga termino ng matematika tinutukoy natin ang operasyong ito bilang conjugation ng Matrix U ito ay pare-pareho sa KSI
brasai bilang density Matrix na naglalarawan ng estado na kinakatawan ng quantum State Vector s at medyo
madaling suriin na partikular kung isasagawa natin ang U sa quantum State Vector Ki kung gayon makukuha natin ang U * Ki at ang
representasyon nito sa density Matrix ay ibinibigay ng Vector na iyon beses ang conjugate transpose nito na U * Ki * brasai * U
dagger kapag ine-evaluate natin ang conjugate transpose ng U * Ki kaya ang paraan ng pagpapakahulugan ng channel na ito
ay may katuturan para sa mga Pure State at kapag pinagsama natin ito sa linearidad makikita natin na ito ay may katuturan para sa mga density matrix sa
pangkalahatan dahil sa katotohanang ang bawat density Matrix ay maaaring ipahayag bilang isang convex combination ng mga pure State ang
kahulugang ito ay palaging nagbibigay sa atin ng isang wastong channel para sa anumang pagpipilian ng isang unitary na operasyon u partikular ang conjugating ng
unitary Matrix tulad nito ay hindi nagbabago ng trace ng isang matrix at kung nag-conjugate tayo ng anumang positive semi-definite
matrix ng anumang Matrix man makakakuha tayo ng isa pang positive semi-definite Matrix at medyo madaling makuha iyon
nang direkta mula sa kahulugan ng mga positive semi-definite matrix kaya ang mga density matrix ay palaging naima-map sa mga density
matrix at lahat ng ito ay nananatiling totoo kahit na na-tensor natin ang U kasama ang identity Matrix ng anumang laki na katumbas nito
ng pag-apply ng channel na ito sa bahagi lamang ng isang compound na sistema narito ang isang talagang simpleng halimbawa ng isang unitary Channel ipagpalagay na
ang U mismo ay ang identity Matrix ito ay malinaw na isang wastong Channel na tinatawag na identity Channel ang
hindi paggawa ng anuman ay tiyak na isang linear na operasyon at kung nagsisimula tayo sa isang density Matrix at hindi tayo gumagawa ng anuman sa ito ito ay
magiging isang density Matrix pa rin kaya ito ay isang wastong Channel gumagamit ang mga tao ng iba't ibang simbolo upang tukuyin ang channel na ito
minsan ito ay eksaktong parehong simbolo na ginagamit natin para sa identity Matrix na maaaring maging kaunting nakakalito ngunit sa pangkalahatan ay hindi narito ginagamit ko ang
mga titik na ID na maiksi para sa identity para lang maiwasan ang anumang kalituhan at ang notasyong ito ay medyo karaniwan rin maaaring mukhang ito ay isang
napaka-boring na Channel ngunit sa konteksto ng paghahatid ng impormasyon ito ay talagang isang perpektong Channel kung saan ang
tatanggap ay nakakakuha nang eksakto kung ano ang ipinapadala ng nagpadala na karaniwan ang nais ng karamihan sa kontekstong iyon isa pang paraan na maaari nating
makakuha ng maraming halimbawa ng mga channel ay ang kumuha ng mga convex combination ng mga channel o sa ibang salita ang pag-average ng mga ito
nang magkasama at ang katotohanang magagawa natin ito ay isang mahalagang aspeto ng mga channel upang ipaliwanag ito nang mas detalyado magsimula tayo sa dalawang channel na F0 at 51
sabihin nating kasama ang isang tunay na numero P sa pagitan ng 0 at isa at para maging malinaw ipinagpapalagay natin na ang dalawang channel na ito ay may
parehong input na sistema na X pati na rin ang parehong output na sistema na Y at ngayon isaalang-alang kung ano ang mangyayari kung magpapasya tayo
na ilapat ang unang channel na F0 na may probabilidad p at kung hindi man ay sa natitirang probabilidad na 1 minus P inilalapat natin
ang ikalawang Channel F1 halimbawa marahil ay random kaming pumipili ng bit na may mga probabilidad na iyon at pagkatapos ginagamit ang random
bit na ito upang matukoy kung aling channel ang ilalapat sa pamamagitan ng paggawa nito epektibo kaming nag-aaplay ng bagong Channel na maaari nating tawaging sigh
na ibinibigay ng isang convex combination ng dalawang channel na sinimulan natin at na maaari nating ipahayag tulad ng nakasulat
sa screen palagi nating makukuha ang mga linear na kumbinasyon ng mga linear na Mapa tulad nito sa pamamagitan ng paraan at ang paraan ng isang linear
kumbinasyon ng mga linear na Mapa ay tinukoy sa isang ibinigay na input na ang ginagawa natin ay ang kumuha ng parehong linear na kumbinasyon ng mga output
na maaaring mukhang medyo trivial ngunit ito ay may katuturan ang output na nakukuha natin mula sa hypothetical na sitwasyong ito ay simpleng ang
weighted average ng mga output na makukuha natin mula sa dalawang orihinal na channel gayon pa man ito ay isang bagong channel at
kung ang ph0 at 51 ay mga wastong channel kung gayon para sa tiyak na ang bagong pagmamapang ito ay magiging isang wastong Channel din isa pang paraan upang sabihin
iyon sa mga termino ng matematika ay ang ang hanay ng lahat ng channel mula sa isang ibinigay na input na sistema patungo sa isang ibinigay na output na sistema ay
convex at iyon ay isang mahalagang katangian ng matematika ng mga channel maaari nating gawin ito nang mas pangkalahatan kung mayroon tayong M channel na 5 0 hanggang f m minus isa sabihin nating
kasama ang probability vector na nagsasabi sa atin kung ano ang probabilidad para sa bawat Channel kung gayon makakakuha tayo ng bagong channel sa pamamagitan ng pag-average ng mga channel ayon doon kaya
sa ilang kahulugan ito ay walang katapusang pinagkukunan ng mga bagong channel halimbawa ang klase ng tinatawag na mga mixed unitary channel ay ang
nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng mga convex combination ng mga unitary channel ibig sabihin kung mayroon tayong M unitary matrix na u0 hanggang u m minus
isa na lahat ay may parehong laki kasama ang probability Vector kung gayon kung kumuha tayo ng weighted average ng mga channel
na tumutugma sa mga indibidwal na unit matrix tulad ng ipinapakita dito sa screen makakakuha tayo ng channel at mga channel
na maaaring isulat tulad nito ay tinatawag na mga mixed unary channel hindi lahat ng channel ay isang mixed unitary Channel hindi natin makukuha ang
bawat channel sa ganitong paraan ngunit sila ay madalas na lumalabas susunod ay titingnan natin ang ilang partikular na
halimbawa ng mga channel lahat sila ay magiging mga halimbawa ng mga channel mula sa isang cubit patungo sa isang cubit na tinatawag na Cubit
channel para sa kaiklian ang una ay tinatawag na Cubit reset Channel at ang ideya ay ang channel na ito ay nagre-reset ng isang cubit
sa zero State dito ginagamit natin ang malalaking titik ng Griyego na Lambda upang tukuyin ang Channel na ito at ang paraan na matandaan mo kung ano ang ginagawa ng channel na ito ay ang
pag-iisip tungkol sa Bloch sphere ang malalaking titik na Lambda ay halos kamukha ng isang arrow na nagtuturo pataas at ang zero state ay nasa tuktok ng Bloch sphere kaya para bang
nagtuturo ito sa lokasyon ng output ang paraan ng kahulugan nito sa mga termino ng matematika ay ang Lambda ng row ay katumbas ng trace ng row beses c0 bra 0 kaya
kung ine-evaluate natin ito sa anumang density Matrix row makukuha natin ang zero State bilang isang density matrix natural na maitanong
kung bakit kailangan natin ng trace hindi ba natin simpleng tukuyin ang Lambda ng row bilang kat zero bra zero nang wala ang trace ng row sa harap
at ang sagot sa tanong na iyon ay hindi ang mga channel ay kailangang maging mga linear na Mapa at hindi ito magiging linear kung aalisin natin ang trace ng row gayundin tandaan na
minsan kailangan nating malaman kung paano gumagana ang isang channel bilang isang linear na pagmamapa sa mga non-density Matrix input halimbawa tulad ng
nakita natin kanina kung gusto nating malaman kung ano ang ginagawa ng isang channel kapag inilapat natin ito sa isang compound na sistema kailangan nating
i-evaluate ang channel na iyon sa mga indibidwal na bloke ng isang mas malaking block Matrix at kahit na ang buong block Matrix ay maaaring maging
isang density Matrix ang mga indibidwal na bloke ay sa pangkalahatan ay hindi magiging isa kaya tingnan natin nang eksakto kung ano ang ginagawa ng channel na ito kapag inilapat natin ito
sa bahagi lamang ng isang compound na sistema at mas partikular kung ano ang ginagawa nito kapag inilapat natin ito sa isa sa dalawang cubit na
bumubuo ng isang ebit upang maging tiyak ipagpalagay na ang A at B ay mga cubit na bilang pares ay nasa fi plus Bell State at inilalapat natin ang Lambda
sa sabihin nating unang Cubit a upang malaman kung ano ang mangyayari unahin muna nating ipahayag ang fi plus State bilang isang density Matrix at
para sa kapakanan ng halimbawang ito gamitin natin ang direct notation upang gawin iyon narito ang fi plus State bilang isang Quantum State vector at narito ang nakukuha natin kapag
pinarami natin ang Vector na ito sa conjugate transpose nito at pinalawak natin lahat ito maaari nating ilapat ang channel sa unang Cubit at i-evaluate ang ating nakukuha narito ay
ang Lambda na inilapat sa unang Cubit at narito ang nakukuha natin kapag ine-evaluate natin ang bawat isa sa mga termino ang trace ng k0o br0 ay isa
at gayundin ang trace ng cat 1 bra 1 kaya sa dalawang kasong iyon ang output ng channel ay cat 0 bra 0 at iyon ang nagpapaliwanag
sa dalawang termino sa sagot ang trace ng Kat zero bra isa sa kabilang banda ay sero tulad ng trace ng Kat 1 bra zero
at kaya ang dalawang terminong iyon ay nag-e-evaluate sa sero at samakatuwid ay hindi nag-aambag ng anuman sa sagot maaari na tayong simplifying ng kaunti
at ang nakukuha natin ay ang zero State para sa unang Cubit na A at ang ganap na mixed state para sa
ikalawang Cubit na B pansinin partikular na hindi tayo nakakuha ng plus state para sa B na hindi kinakailangang
isang masamang hula kung wala tayong alam tungkol sa mga density matrix at tiningnan lang natin ang quantum State Vector na representasyon ng estado ngunit iyon
ay hindi kung paano gumagana ang channel na ito at walang channel na posibleng gumana nang ganoon ang channel na Lambda ay tinatawag na Cubit reset Channel ngunit ang
paraan ng paggana nito ay mas katulad ng pagtatapon ng input cubit sa basurahan at pagpapalit nito ng sariwang cubit sa zero state ngunit ito nga ay ang
tanging Cubit channel na palaging nag-o-output ng zero State narito ang isa pang halimbawa ng isang cubit Channel na kilala bilang
ganap na dephasing Channel ito ay tinutukoy ng Delta at ang paraan ng paggana nito ay iniiwan ang diagonal
mga entry ng anumang 2x2 matrix nang mag-isa at ini-zero out ang mga off diagonal na entry ang Delta ay ang katumbas ng Griyego na titik ng D sa
Latin na alpabeto at iyon ay maikli para sa diagonal kaya iyon ay isang paraan upang matandaan kung ano ang ginagawa ng channel na ito maaari rin
nating ipahayag ang channel na ito gamit ang direct notation tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen at para maging malinaw ang
output ay palaging isang 2X dalawang Matrix kaya partikular na ang dalawang zero output ay tumutukoy sa lahat ng zero 2x dalawang Matrix madalas naming
ginagawa ito at nakita natin ito noon sa seryeng ito ang simbolo na zero ay karaniwang ginagamit marahil nang ambiguous upang mangahulugang zero
elemento ng anumang bagay na pinag-uusapan natin kung ito ay mga scalar vector matrix o anuman gawin natin ang parehong bagay na ginawa natin dati para sa
Cubit reset Channel at tingnan kung ano ang mangyayari kung inilalapat natin ang channel na ito sa kalahati ng isang ebit ang setup ay pareho kaya hindi na ako mag-
dadaan sa bahaging iyon at ang resulta ay ang estado na ipinapakita sa screen na karaniwang isang shared random bit kaya ang
ginawa ng channel na ito ay karaniwang ang pag-convert ng isang ebit sa isang perfectly correlated na pares ng mga klasikal na random bit
at iyon ay pare-pareho sa isang mas pangkalahatang interpretasyon ng channel na ito sa pamamagitan ng pag-zero out ng mga off diagonal na entry ng isang density Matrix epektibo naming
itinatapon ang quantum na bagay sa isang density Matrix na nag-iiwan ng isang diagonal density Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang
klasikal na probabilistikong Estado isa pang paraan upang isipin ito ay ang channel na ito ay kumakatawan sa isang perpektong walang ingay na klasikal na channel na nagpapadala ng isang bit
kaya kung naglalagay tayo ng zero state o isang state o isang convex combination ng dalawang estado na iyon sa channel kung gayon ang estado ay lumalabas nang walang pagbabago ngunit kung susubukan mong
maglagay ng Quantum State dito tulad ng isang plus state halimbawa para bang sinusukat ng channel ang estado na iyon gamit ang isang standard basis measurement at pagkatapos ay
ipinagpadala ang klasikal na resulta isang huling halimbawa ng isang cubit channel ay ang ganap na depolarizing Channel kung ano
ang ginagawa ng channel na ito ay palaging nag-o-output ng ganap na mixed state kaya ito ay katulad sa ilang kahulugan ng Cubit reset
Channel maliban na nakakakuha tayo ng mas hindi kapaki-pakinabang na ganap na mixed state kaysa sa isang inisyalisadong Cubit isang natural na paraan
upang isipin ang channel na ito ay kinakatawan nito ang isang matinding anyo ng ingay at sa mga Cubit channel ay
talagang hindi na maaaring maging mas maingay kaysa rito wala akong magandang mnemonic na ibabahagi para sa pag-alala kung ano ang ginagawa ng isang ito maliban sa pagsabi na ang Omega ay ang huli
na titik ng Griyego na alpabeto at minsan ito ay nauugnay sa katapusan ng lahat ng mga bagay at marahil ito ang mangyayari
sa lahat ng cubit sa huli pagdating sa ingay medyo extreme ngunit isang bagay na magagawa natin ay ang isaalang-alang ang isang convex
kumbinasyon ng Channel na ito at ang identity Channel na marahil ay may maliit na probabilidad na Epsilon para sa kumpletong
depolarization ito ay isang hindi gaanong matinding anyo ng ingay kung saan ang isang ibinigay na Cubit state ay karaniwang maiiwanan nang mag-isa ngunit mayroong
maliit na pagkakataon na ito ay ganap na mixed geometrically maaari nating isipin ito bilang isang bahagyang pagkontrata ng Bloch sphere patungo sa gitna
at sa pamamagitan ng paraan maaari rin tayong gumawa ng katulad na bagay sa ganap na dephasing Channel upang i-model ang proseso ng decoherence halimbawa kung saan ang mga bagay
ay nagiging bahagyang mas klasikal sa pamamagitan ng ilang proseso kaya iyon ang tatlong pangunahing halimbawa ng mga Cubit channel at
babalik tayo sa kanila pangunahin bilang pinagkukunan ng mga halimbawa sa buong natitirang bahagi ng aralin susunod tatalakayin natin ang matematika
na mga representasyon ng mga channel simula sa isang pangunahing tanong ang mga linear na pagmamapa mula sa mga vector patungo sa mga vector ay maaaring palaging
kinakatawan ng mga matrix sa isang pamilyar na paraan na ang aksyon ng linear na pagmamapa ay inilarawan ng matrix
Vector na multiplikasyon ngunit ang mga channel ay mga linear na pagmamapa mula sa mga matrix patungo sa mga matrix hindi mga vector patungo sa mga vector kaya sa
pangkalahatan paano natin maaaring ipahayag ang mga channel sa mga termino ng matematika minsan para sa mga espesyal na channel magkakaroon tayo ng simpleng formula
na naglalarawan sa kanila at iyon ang naging kaso sa mga halimbawa ng mga Cubit channel na tinalakay na natin ngunit iyon ay hindi
praktikal sa pangkalahatan dahil hindi palaging may ganoong magandang formula bilang isang punto ng paghahambing sa pinasimpleng
pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon gumagamit tayo ng mga unitary matrix upang katawanin ang mga operasyon sa mga Quantum State vector
bawat unitary Matrix ay kumakatawan sa isang wastong operasyon at bawat wastong operasyon ay maaaring ipahayag bilang isang unitary Matrix kaya sa
esensya ang tanong na ito ay nagtatanong kung paano natin gagawin ito para sa mga channel at ang sagot sa tanong na ito ay ang mayroon sa katunayan ng maraming paraan upang katawanin ang
mga channel sa mga termino ng matematika partikular na tatalakayin natin ang tatlong magkakaibang paraan ng pagkatawan ng mga channel na
pinangalanan sa tatlong indibidwal na ang gawa ay gumanap ng mahalagang papel sa kanilang pagpapaunlad ang Stinespring Krauss at Choi
una makikita natin kung paano gumagana ang iba't ibang representasyong ito at pagkatapos sa huling bahagi ng aralin makikita natin kung paano nauugnay ang tatlong representasyon at sa
partikular kung paano tayo maaaring mag-convert sa pagitan nila makikita rin natin na ang mga representasyong ito ay tumpak na kumukuha ng mga kinakailangan na mayroon tayo sa mga channel
katulad ng ang mga ito ay mga linear na pagmamapa at palagi silang nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix kahit noong
inilalapat sila sa bahagi lamang ng isang compound na sistema una ay ang mga Stinespring representation si Willam Forest Stine
spring ay isang matematisyan na hindi nagtrabaho sa Quantum na impormasyon at ang mga Stinespring representation tulad ng aking ilalarawan
ay sa ilang kahulugan ay isang derivative lamang ng kanyang gawa sa operator theory noong 1950s ngunit ang gawang ito ay tiyak na
isang mahalagang bahagi ng pagpapaunlad ng matematika na ang Quantum channel ay batay ang ideya sa likod ng paraan ng pagkatawan ng mga channel na ito ay ang bawat
channel ay maaaring ipatupad sa isang tiyak na paraan na aking ilalarawan ngayon una bumubuo tayo ng isang compound na sistema na binubuo ng
input sa anumang Channel na ating ipinapatupad kasama ang isang inisyalisadong workspace system pagkatapos ay isang
unitary na operasyon ang isinasagawa sa Compound na sistema at sa wakas anumang bahagi ng resultang compound na sistema
na tumutugma sa output ng channel ay iniiwanan nang mag-isa o naka-output at ang natitira ay itinatapon o naka-traced out nakakatulong na
ipahayag ito sa anyo ng isang diagram at ito ay pinakasimple na simulan sa espesyal na kaso kung saan ang input at ang
output na sistema ay pareho ang diagram na ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay tulad ng isang Quantum circuit diagram maliban na ang mga wire
ay kumakatawan sa mga arbitrary na sistema at hindi kinakailangang mga solong cubit kaya nagsisimula tayo sa input na sistema X na nasa ilang
Estado row nagpapakilala tayo ng isang inisyalisadong workspace system W at sa diagram na ito ipinagpapalagay ko na ang Zer ay isang klasikal
estado ng w at kinukuha natin ang k0 bilang inisyalisadong estado ng sistema ngunit maaari rin nating ayusin ang anumang pure state
ng w at tingnan iyon bilang inisyalisadong estado pagkatapos ay isinasagawa natin ang ilang unitary na operasyon sa pares na WX at pagkatapos ay
ini-trace out ang workspace system at ini-output ang X dito sa diagram sa pamamagitan ng paraan ginagamit ko ang ground symbol mula sa
electrical engineering upang ipahiwatig na ang W ay itinatapon hindi iyon kinakailangang pangkaraniwan at hindi mo
makikita ang simbolo na iyon sa Qiskit doon ay binabalewala mo lang ang mga cubit na hindi mo kailangan ang punto ay nais ko lang magkaroon ng simbolo na nagpapalinaw
na itinatapon natin ang sistema para sa mga layunin ng talakayan na ito sa pangkalahatan hindi kinakailangan
na pareho ang input at output na sistema kaya maaari tayong magkaroon halimbawa ng isang output na sistema Y kasama ang isang garbage
sistema G na naka-traced out upang maging unitary ang U dapat itong maging isang square Matrix kaya mayroong isang assumption
dito na ang pares na g y magkasama ay may parehong bilang ng mga klasikal na estado bilang ang pares na WX halimbawa marahil ang mga sistema na ito
ay binubuo ng mga cubit at ang input na sistema X ay binubuo ng 5 cubit at ang W ay binubuo ng 10 cubit sabihin nating kaya ang U ay isang unitary
na operasyon sa 15 cubit maaaring pagkatapos ay ang Y ay binubuo ng 4 cubit lamang na nangangahulugang ang G ay binubuo ng 11 cubit
o marahil ang mga ito ay hindi mga cubit lahat ang mahalaga ay ang WX magkasama at gy magkasama ay may parehong bilang ng
mga klasikal na estado upang maaari kang maging unitary ang isang paglalarawan ng isang channel tulad nito ay tinatawag na isang Stinespring representation ng channel ngayon ito ay
medyo simpleng magtaltalo na ang anumang pagmamapa na fi na maaaring ilarawan sa ganitong paraan ay talagang isang wastong channel sa
partikular kung magsisimula tayo sa density Matrix at pagkatapos ay idikit ang karagdagang workspace system kung gayon tiyak na mananatili tayo sa
isang density Matrix napansin na natin na ang pag-apply ng unitary na operasyon ay nagbibigay sa atin ng wastong Channel at
kung mayroon tayong density Matrix ng isang compound na sistema at nag-trace out tayo ng isa sa mga sistema kung gayon muli ay mananatili tayo sa isang density Matrix kaya kapag inayos
natin ang mga hakbang na ito matitiyak nating palaging nagbabago ito ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix at ito rin ay linear
kung ano ang hindi malinaw sa puntong ito ay ang bawat channel ay maaaring ipatupad sa ganitong paraan para sa ilang pagpipilian
ng workspace system at ang garbage system pati na rin ang unitary na operasyon U siyempre ngunit iyon ay totoo at
makikita natin kung bakit sa pagtatapos ng aralin narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang Stinespring representation para sa ganap na def
phasing Cubit Channel at para maging malinaw ngayon ang mga wire ay mga cubit at ito ay isang ordinaryong controlled
not gate medyo simple ang input Cubit ay nasa itaas at nagpapakilala tayo ng isang workspace Cubit na inisyalisado sa zero
state pagkatapos ay nagsasagawa tayo ng controlled not na operasyon kung saan ang input Cubit ay ang kontrol at ang workspace Cubit ay ang
Target at pagkatapos ang workspace Cubit ay naka-traced out intuitive na nagsasalita ito ay may katuturan
na ito ay dapat na ipatupad ang ganap na def phasing Channel dahil ang controlled not gate ay halos kumikilos tulad ng isang standard basis measurement sa itaas
Cubit sa pamamagitan ng pagkopya ng klasikal na estado nito sa ibabang Cubit at pagkatapos ang resulta ay itinapon
ngunit maaari rin tayong dumaan sa isang kalkulasyon at siyempre ito ay isang magandang ideya na gawin iyon dahil talagang kailangan natin
huwag masyadong magtiwala sa ating intuisyon maaari tayong magsimula sa pamamagitan ng pagsulat ng density Matrix na representasyon ng
dalawang cubit pagkatapos maisama ang workspace Cubit at pansinin na ginagamit natin ang kubit ordering Convention tulad ng
karaniwan kung saan ang ibabang Cubit ay ang kaliwa at ang itaas na Cubit ay nasa kanan maaari nating ipahayag ang density Matrix na ito
nang tahasan bilang isang aktwal na 4x4 Matrix tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen at pagkatapos ay kinukwenta natin ang epekto
na mayroon ang controlled not gate sa density Matrix na ito kaya nag-conjugate tayo gamit ang unitary Matrix na nauugnay sa
gate na ito muli na tinatandaan ang kubit ordering convention kaya ito ang tamang unitary
Matrix at ang resulta ay ipinapakita dito sa epekto ang controlled not gate
ay nagpalipat-lipat ng mga entry ng ating orihinal na Matrix kaunti kaya ngayon ang mga posibleng hindi-zero na entry ay nasa
apat na sulok natitira pa ring kwentahin ang partial trace at maaari nating gawin iyon nang direkta mula sa Matrix ngunit isang
alternatibo ay ang mag-convert sa direct notation tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen at pagkatapos magiging medyo madaling i-evaluate
kung ano ang mangyayari kapag nag-trace tayo ng Cubit sa kaliwa sa loob ng bawat termino at ang resulta ay ang lamang ang
mga termino na tumutugma sa diagonal na mga entry ng row ang nananatili at kaya nai-phase na natin ang Cubit tulad ng
inaasahan tulad ng palagi suriin ito para sa iyong sarili sa iyong sariling bilis kung pipiliin mong gawin iyon ito ay isang magandang
halimbawa upang makakuha ng ilang pagsasanay sa pagtatrabaho sa mga density matrix at sa mga partial
trace iyon ay hindi ang tanging paraan upang ipatupad ang ganap na def phasing Channel narito ang isang alternatibong Stinespring representation para sa
channel na ito hindi ko dadaanan ang kalkulasyon nang detalyado sa video na ito ngunit ipapakita ko ito nang maikli kung sakaling gusto mong i-pause ang video at
mas malapitan ang pagtingin ang paraan ng paggana nito ay katulad sa una ngunit ang mga detalye ay
naiiba sa pagkakataong ito nagsisimula tayo sa isang Hadamard gate sa workspace Cubit na naglalagay nito sa isang plus State at kung
pinalawak natin ang tensor product makukuha natin ang Matrix na ipinapakita sa screen upang ilapat ang control zgate
nag-conjugate tayo gamit ang nauugnay na unitary Matrix at ang resulta ng paggawa nito ay ang pag-inject ng ilang minus sign sa
Matrix partikular ang huling row at huling column ay parehong nini-multiply ng negatibo 1
at sa pagkakataong ito ay magiging medyo magulo ang pag-convert sa direct notation kaya ikukwenta natin ang partial trace
nang direkta kapag nag-trace tayo ng una sa dalawang cubit ang nakukuha natin sa wakas ay ang kabuuan ng dalawang diagonal 2x dalawang bloke
at kaya ang huling resulta ay muli na na-defase natin ang Cubit iyon ay mabilis at kung ikaw ay hindi
sanay sa ganitong uri ng mga kalkulasyon kung gayon mag-ingat at gawin ito nang dahan-dahan ang bilis ay hindi mahalaga
dito upang tapusin ang halimbawang ito hayaan akong banggitin na mayroong medyo simpleng ideya sa likod ng implementasyong ito na
magandang naipahayag ng huling hakbang ng kalkulasyon na sandali lang nating tiningnan isang mas maikli na paraan ng pagsasabi nito
ay ang kung ina-average natin ang isang ibinigay na Cubit density Matrix kasama ang density Matrix na iyon na conjugated ng poly Z Matrix kung gayon
iyon ay kapareho ng dephasing kaya ang ganap na dephasing Channel ay nangyaring maging isang mixed unitary
Channel kung saan alinman ay hindi natin ginagawa o sa ibang salita isinasagawa natin ang identity na operasyon o isinasagawa natin ang isang zgate bawat isa
na may probabilidad na 1/2 magandang malaman kaya sa buod mayroon tayong dalawang magkaibang
Stinespring representation ng ganap na dephasing Channel at iyon ay nagsasabi sa atin ng isang mahalagang bagay na ang mga Stinespring representation ay
hindi natatangi at sa katunayan ay mayroon talagang walang katapusang bilang ng mga ito para sa anumang ibinigay na Channel susunod ay tatalakayin natin ang Krauss
mga representasyon ng mga channel na nagbibigay sa atin ng isang maginhawang formulaic na paraan ng pagpapahayag ng mga channel sa pamamagitan ng matrix
multiplikasyon at karagdagan ang mga Krauss representation ay pinangalanan kay Carl Krauss na isang pisiko na bukod sa
iba pang mga bagay ay nagtrabaho ng maraming pangunahing detalye sa matematika ng mga channel at ang pangkalahatang pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon nang mas malawak sa pangkalahatan isang
Krauss representation ay isang pagpapahayag ng isang channel na kumukuha ng anyo na ipinapakita dito sa screen partikular mayroon tayong isang
koleksyon ng mga matrix na dito ay pinangalanang a z hanggang a n minus isa para sa ilang positibong integer n at tinutukoy nila ang
aksyon ng channel sa anumang ibinigay na input row ayon sa formula sa madaling salita nag-conjugate tayo ng row sa bawat isa sa mga matrix na ito
na madalas na tinutukoy bilang mga Krauss matrix sa kontekstong ito at pagkatapos isinasama natin ang resulta at iyon ay nagbibigay sa atin ng output lahat ng matrix na ito ay dapat magkaroon ng
parehong dimensyon at partikular ang kanilang mga column ay dapat tumugma sa mga klasikal na estado ng input na sistema at
ang mga row ay dapat tumugma sa mga klasikal na estado ng output na sistema kung iyon ang kaso kung gayon kapag kinuha natin ang product na AK * row * AK dagger para sa anumang
pagpipilian ng K nakakakuha tayo ng isang square Matrix na ang mga row at column ay tumutugma sa mga klasikal na estado ng output na sistema
at kaya ito ay may katuturan na ang ekspresyon ay gumagawa ng isang density Matrix ng output na sistema ngayon hindi iyon ang kaso
na para sa isang arbitrary na pagpipilian ng mga Krauss matrix na ito makakakuha tayo ng isang wastong Channel ngunit mayroong medyo simpleng
kondisyon sa mga matrix na ginagarantiyahan na makakakuha tayo ng isang wastong Channel at ang kondisyong iyon ay ang formula na ipinapakita dito mismo
partikular kung isinasama natin ang product ng AK dagger * AK sa lahat ng halaga ng K
kung gayon dapat nating makuha ang identity Matrix at iyon ay magiging identity Matrix na ang mga row at column ay tumutugma sa
mga klasikal na estado ng input na sistema kaya ang kondisyong iyon ay dapat matugunan upang ang pagmamapa na tinukoy ng
unang equation ay maging isang wastong Channel at lumabas na ang bawat channel ay talagang may isang representasyon na kumukuha ng
ganitong anyo basta sapat na ang laki ng n narito ang ilang halimbawa ng mga Krauss
representation simula sa Cubit reset Channel maaari tayong makakuha ng isang Krauss representation para sa channel na ito sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng
dalawang Krauss matrix na c0 bra 0 at c0 bra isa kaya ang n ay katumbas ng dalawa sa halimbawang ito
maaari nating i-plug ang mga pagpipiliang ito sa pangkalahatang formula at mayroon tayong dalawang termino lamang kaya madaling isulat ang kabuuan
at kung isimplify natin at kilalanin na ang ekspresyon sa panaklong ay ang trace ng row makikita natin na nakukuha natin
ang Cubit reset Channel maaari rin nating suriin na ang kinakailangang kondisyon sa mga matrix na ito ay natutugunan at iyon ay simpleng bagay ng pag-plug ng Krauss
matrix sa equation at pag-evaluate at makukuha natin ang identity Matrix tulad ng kinakailangan para sa isa pang halimbawa muli nating tingnan ang
ganap na dephasing Channel ang pagkuha ng mga matrix na cat 0 br0 at Cat one bra isa ay gumagana at maaaring masuri iyon sa
pamamagitan ng pagpapalawak ng kabuuan at medyo direktang makita na nakukuha natin ang kailangan natin at muli ang kinakailangang kondisyon ay natutugunan isang
alternatibo ay ang kumuha ng a z bilang identity Matrix ided divided by square root ng 2 at A1 bilang
Sigma Z divided by square root ng 2 at kung ine-evaluate natin ay makikita natin na muli ay nakukuha natin ang ganap na dephasing Channel batay sa obserbasyon
na ginawa natin tungkol sa channel na ito nang kaunti kanina sa aralin at muli ang kinakailangang kondisyon ay medyo simpleng
suriin bilang isang ehersisyo na dapat gawin kung mahahanap mo itong kapaki-pakinabang isaalang-alang ang ganap na depolarizing
Channel na nag-o-output ng ganap na mixed state para sa bawat density Matrix input para sa isang ito apat na Krauss matrix
ang kinakailangan hindi posible na makabuo ng isang Krauss representation kung saan ang n ay tatlo o mas kaunti narito ang isang pagpipilian na gumagana at
narito ang isa pa kaya ang ehersisyo ay i-verify na gumagana ang mga pagpipiliang ito pati na rin suriin na ang kinakailangang kondisyon
ay natutugunan sulit na ituro na ang ikalawang alternatibo ay karaniwang nagsasabi na posible na ganap na i-depolarize ang isang cubit o sa ibang salita
ganap na i-randomize ito sa pamamagitan ng random na pagpili ng isa sa apat na Pauli matrix kabilang ang identity at pag-apply ng
kaukulang unitary na operasyon sa Cubit at kaya ang ganap na depolarizing channel ay isa pang halimbawa ng isang mixed
unitary channel ang huli sa tatlong representasyon ng Channel na tatalakayin natin ay ang Choi representation si Manduin Choi
ay isang matematisyan na nagtatrabaho sa Matrix Theory at iba pang mga paksa at ang Choi representation ay pinangalanan sa karangalan niya
batay sa isang talagang eleganteng papel na inilathala niya noong 1975 na sa ilang kahulugan ay nagtitali ng lahat ng bagay na ito nang magkasama ang Choi
representation ng isang channel f ay isang solong Matrix na karaniwan ay tinutukoy ng jfi at partikular kung ang
input na sistema ay may n klasikal na estado at ang output na sistema ay may M klasikal na estado kung gayon ang Choi representation ng f ay magiging
isang n * m by n * m square Matrix bago ko sabihin sa iyo kung paano eksaktong tinukoy ang Matrix nais kong banggitin ang ilang
mga pangunahing katangian nito na nag-uudyok sa representasyon sa isang paraan na ang aktwal na kahulugan mismo ay maaaring hindi sa hindi bababa sa
ibabaw una hindi tulad ng parehong mga Stinespring representation at Krauss representation ang Choi representation
ay isang tinatawag na tapat na representasyon na nangangahulugang ang bawat channel ay mayroon lamang ng isa nito at iyon ay medyo mahalaga
dahil sinasabi nito na ang dalawang channel ay pareho kung at tanging kung ang kanilang mga Choi representation ay pareho kaya kung ikaw ay
mayroong dalawang magkaibang paglalarawan ng mga channel tulad ng dalawang magkaibang Stinespring representation o dalawang magkaibang Krauss representation o marahil isa sa
bawat isa at gusto mong malaman kung sila ay talagang parehong channel maaari kang simpleng kwentahin ang Choi representation at
suriin kung pareho ba o hindi ang ikalawang katangian ay ang mayroong simpleng susuriin ang mga kondisyon sa Choi representation na totoo kung at tanging kung
mayroon tayong wastong channel hindi iyon masyadong espesyal maaari nating sabihin ang parehong bagay tungkol sa dalawa pang representasyon ngunit ito ay isang magandang katangian
na magkaroon gayunpaman at tatalakayin pa natin ito nang mas detalyado sa lalong madaling panahon isa pang bagay na tandaan tungkol sa Choi representation ay bagaman tayo ay
nagtatawan ng channel gamit ang isang matrix ang Matrix na ito ay hindi direktang kumakatawan sa channel bilang isang linear na pagmamapa sa katunayan ito ay
mas natural na maiugnay ang Choi representation sa density Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang tiyak na Estado
kaysa sa pag-iisip tungkol sa Choi representation bilang naglalarawan ng isang linear na pagmamapa gayunpaman posible na maibalik ang aksyon ng channel mula sa
Choi representation nito gamit ang isang medyo simpleng formula ngunit hindi ito kasing simple ng ordinaryong matrix
multiplikasyon sapat na ang paunang salita ngayon pumunta sa aktwal na kahulugan ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong isang channel na fi mula sa isang sistema X patungo sa isang sistema Y
at ipagpalagay na ang classical State set ng input na sistema X ay Sigma hindi natin kailangang tukuyin ang classical State set ng output na sistema kaya
para sa kahulugan walang pangangailangan na pangalanan ang isa ang Choi representation ng fi ay tinukoy ng ekspresyon
na ipinapakita dito sa screen mayroon tayong kabuuan na sumasaklaw sa lahat ng klasikal na estado A at B para sa input na sistema at nag-i-sum tayo
ng k a bra B tensored kasama ang channel na fi na inilapat sa k a bra B kaya ang
representasyong ito ay tinukoy ng isang formula at mayroong ilang magkaibang paraan na maaari nating isipin ang formula na ito bago ko talakayin ang mga ito gayunpaman hayaan akong
banggitin na minsan ang Choi representation ay tinukoy sa bahagyang magkaibang paraan kung saan ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng dalawang tensor factor ay binaliktad ibig sabihin
na ang fi ng k a bra ay lumalabas bilang unang tensor Factor kaysa sa ikalawa ngunit ang dalawang magkaibang paraan ng paggawa nito ay
katumbas hanggang sa simpleng symmetry na ito ngunit ang ibig sabihin nito ay kapag ginagamit mo ang representasyong ito ay isang magandang
ideya na linawin kung aling pagkakasunod-sunod ang ginagamit mo ang pagkakasunod-sunod na ito ang paraan ng paggawa nito sa Qiskit at ito rin ay mas mainam para sa
paglarawan ng representasyon nang biswal sa mga tuntunin ng block matrix kaya ito ang isang susundang natin upang maging mas tiyak tungkol sa block Matrix
paglalarawan kung ipagpalagay natin na ang classical State set na Sigma ay binubuo ng mga integer mula sero hanggang n minus isa
para sa ilang positibong integer n kung gayon maaari nating alternatibong isulat ang jfi bilang isang block Matrix tulad ng ipinapakita dito mismo sa
screen sa ibang salita ang Choi representation ng fi ay ang Matrix na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-evaluate ng fi sa bawat isa sa
mga input matrix na may eksaktong isang entry na katumbas ng isa kasama ang lahat ng kanilang mga entry na sero at pagkatapos pag-ayos ng mga ito
sa isang Matrix sa isang medyo natural na paraan maaaring hindi malinaw kung bakit gusto nating bumuo ng matrix tulad nito ngunit ito
ay talagang kapaki-pakinabang isang bagay na mapapansin ay ang hanay na naglalaman ng mga matrix na k a bra b habang ang
a at b ay parehong sumasaklaw sa lahat ng integer mula 0 hanggang n minus isa ay bumubuo ng isang batayan para sa espasyo ng lahat ng n byn matrix kaya kung
mayroon kang Matrix na ito maaari mong tiyak na matukoy kung ano ang ginagawa ng fi sa isang arbitrary na n byn matrix sa pamamagitan ng linearidad
partikular sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng naaangkop na mga linear na kumbinasyon ng mga bloke kaya ang Matrix jfi ay talagang natatanging
tinutukoy ang fi bilang isang linear na pagmamapa isa pang paraan upang isipin ang Choi representation ng isang channel ay ang
kinakatawan nito ng isang estado bilang isang density Matrix kapag ito ay na-normalize partikular sa pamamagitan ng paghahati nito sa bilang ng
mga klasikal na estado ng input na sistema na patuloy kong tutukuyin ng lowercase n palagi itong magbibigay sa atin ng isang
density Matrix na madalas na tinutukoy bilang Choi state ng channel narito ang kung paano ito gumagana nang mas detalyado
isipin muna na mayroon tayong dalawang magkaparehong kopya ng input na sistema at isinalang-alang natin ang quantum State Vector s
na ipinapakita sa screen na kumakatawan sa isang tinatawag na maximally entangled state ng pares ng magkaparehong sistema na ito para sa
halimbawa kung ang Sigma ay ang binary na alpabeto kung gayon ito ay isang f+ state ngunit maaari tayong mag-isip tungkol sa isang analogously na tinukoy na estado para sa
anumang pagpipilian ng Sigma at ang nakukuha natin ay isang estado na highly entangled at sa katunayan ito ay kasing entangled mo na maaaring makuha
sa pagpipiliang ito ng mga sistema upang makuha ang density Matrix na representasyon ng estado pinaramihin natin ang state Vector sa conjugate transpose nito tulad ng karaniwan at
ganito ang hitsura nito at sa wakas kung iisipin natin ang Choi representation ng channel na hinati ng n makikita natin na ito ay ang estado na
makukuha natin kung ilalapat natin ang channel na fi sa ikalawang sistema sa anyo ng figure narito
ang hitsura nito mayroon tayong dalawang kopya ng sistema X sa maximally entangled State s ang channel f ay
inilapat sa ikalawang sistema na nasa itaas sa diagram at ang resultang estado ay ang Choi state ng lima siyempre hindi tayo karaniwan
magbibigay ng parehong pangalan sa dalawang magkaibang sistema tulad nito sa pangkalahatan ay hindi kapaki-pakinabang na bigyan ng parehong pangalan ang dalawang magkaibang bagay ngunit ito ay may katuturan
sa kasong ito para lamang gawin ang koneksyong ito sa mga Choi representation mayroon ilang implikasyon na maaari nating agad na iguhit mula sa paraan ng
pagtingin sa mga Choi representation isa ay ang dahil ang Choi state ay isang density Matrix ipinagpapalagay na ang f ay isang
wastong Channel kaya nating tapusin na ang Choi representation ng fi ay dapat na positive semi-definite tandaan na ito ay isang
kinakailangan na inilalagay natin sa mga channel na palagi silang nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix at ito
ay isang espesyal na kaso lamang nito ang ikalawang implikasyon ay ang kung kinuha natin ang Choi state para sa anumang channel na fi at
pagkatapos itinatapon ang output na sistema Y dapat kaming matirang ganap na mixed state sa input na sistema X iyon ay
dahil ang pag-apply ng channel sa isang sistema at pagkatapos ay pagtatapon ng resultang sistema sa basurahan ay katumbas ng basta pagtatapon ng orihinal na sistema sa
basurahan at kung gagawin natin iyon sa ating maximally entangled State ang density Matrix na matitirang natin ay magiging
ang identity Matrix na hinati ng n o sa ibang salita ang ganap na mixed state para sa sistema X ang ideya sa mas
matematikal na termino ay ang pag-compose ng anumang Channel kasama ang trace sa output na sistema ay dapat na katumbas ng trace sa
input na sistema at iyon ay dahil ang mga channel ay dapat na mapanatili ang trace dahil sa katotohanang sila ay mga linear na pagmamapa na
palaging nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix kapag mayroon na tayong equation na ito maaari nating i-clear ang denominator n
mula sa magkabilang panig upang makakuha ng bahagyang mas malinis na kondisyon sa salita ang pagsasagawa ng partial trace sa output na sistema
ng Choi representation ng isang channel ay dapat magbigay sa atin ng identity Matrix sa input na sistema kaya sa buod ang mga Choi
representation ng mga channel ay palaging positive semi-definite at kung nag-trace tayo ng output na sistema kinakailangan tayong
matirang may identity Matrix sa input na sistema tulad ng lumabas na ito ay hindi lamang kinakailangang mga kondisyon kundi
sila rin ay sapat ibig sabihin kung ang I ay isang arbitrary na linear na pagmamapa at ang dalawang kondisyong ito ay parehong totoo
kung gayon dapat na talagang isang wastong Channel ang fi at makikita natin kung bakit iyon ang kaso sa pagtatapos ng aralin
tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa simula sa ganap na dephasing channel upang kwentahin ang Choi representation ito ay simpleng bagay ng
pag-evaluate ng formula ang ganap na dephasing Channel ay nag-iiwan ng k a bra B nang mag-isa kapag a katumbas B at kung hindi man ang output
ay sero kaya ang mga termino sa kabuuan na nakaligtas ay ang mga kung saan ang a ay katumbas ng B at ang resulta ay ipinahahayag sa
screen gamit ang direct notation maaari rin nating tingnan ito bilang isang block Matrix ang Delta ay nag-iiwang mag-isa ang mga diagonal na entry at ini-zero out ang mga off
diagonal na entry at kaya natitirang may matrix na may mga isa sa kaliwang itaas at kanang ibabang mga sulok kasama ang lahat ng
kanilang mga entry na sero at iyon ay pare-pareho sa unang ekspresyon para sa isa pang halimbawa isaalang-alang natin ang ganap na depolarizing Channel muli tayo
ay maaaring magsimula sa pagsulat ng formula at tulad ng sa nakaraang halimbawa ay hindi tayo nakakakuha ng anumang kontribusyon sa kabuuan
kapag ang a ay hindi katumbas ng B at sa pagkakataong ito kapag ang a ay katumbas ng B nakakakuha tayo ng ganap na mixed state at maaari nating simplify iyon sa
makakuha ng 1/2 * ang 2x2 identity Matrix na tensored sa sarili nito na 1/2 * ang 4x4
identity Matrix maaari rin nating isipin ito sa mga tuntunin ng block matrix at natural na nakakakuha tayo ng parehong resulta at bilang
huling halimbawa isaalang-alang natin ang identity channel para sa isang solong Cubit ito ay madaling isa narito ang formula at siyempre ang
identity Channel ay hindi gumagawa ng anuman at maaari nating isipin ang resulta bilang dalawang beses ng density Matrix na nauugnay sa isang f+ state at iyon ay
pare-pareho sa inaasahan natin sa pag-iisip tungkol sa Choi state ng Channel na ito at narito ito bilang isang block Matrix pansinin partikular na ang Choi
representation ng identity channel ay hindi ang identity matrix ito ang Matrix na ito nakita na natin ang tatlong magkaibang
paraan upang katawanin ang mga channel sa matematika katulad ng mga Stinespring representation Krauss representation at Choi
representation mayroon din tayong kahulugan ng isang channel na ang isang channel ay isang linear na pagmamapa na palaging
nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix kahit kapag ang channel ay inilalapat sa bahagi lamang ng isang compound na sistema isang napaka natural at napaka mahalagang
tanong na itatanong sa puntong ito ay kung paano natin malalaman na ang mga bagay na ito ay lahat ay katumbas halimbawa kung paano natin malalaman na ang bawat
pagmamapa na inilarawan ng alinman sa mga representasyong ito ay talagang isang wastong Channel at kung paano natin malalaman na hindi tayo nag-iiwan ng anumang channel ang
natitirang bahagi ng aralin ay nagpapaliwanag kung paano ang lahat ng ito ay maaaring mapag-isipan sa matematika kung handang tanggapin mo ang katumbasan ng mga bagay na ito at hindi ka interesado kung paano ito maaaring
mapag-isipan kung gayon huwag kang mag-atubiling laktawan ang natitirang bahagi ng video ngunit personal na sa tingin ko ang argumento ay medyo
maganda at ito ay isang magandang halimbawa ng isang partikular na estilo ng patunay sa matematika na lumalabas sa oras-oras sa teorya ng quantum na impormasyon hindi ko
dadaanan ang lahat ng mga detalye ang ilan ay iiwan ko para sa iyo o mahahanap mo ang mga ito sa nakasulat na nilalaman para sa araling ito kung saan ang lahat ay nakalagay
nang detalyado ngunit umaasa akong makapagpakita ng makatwirang malinaw na larawan kung paano gumagana ang lahat ang gusto nating gawin ay patunayan ang
katumbasan ng isang koleksyon ng mga pahayag at ang paraan ng magagawa natin ito ay ang mag-set up ng isang cycle ng mga implikasyon partikular magsisimula tayo
sa kahulugan ng isang channel ibig sabihin ng isang linear na pagmamapa na palaging nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix
mula sa kahulugang ito maaari tayong magtaltalo na ang Choi representation ng channel na ito ay dapat matugunan ang dalawang kondisyon na ating
natukoy na at sa katunayan nagawa na natin ito ito ay tinalakay sa konteksto ng Choi state ng isang channel pagkatapos ay nakakalimutan tayo ng lahat
tungkol sa kahulugan at nagtatrabaho tayo mula sa Choi representation at ibinibigay ang ating dalawang kondisyon sa mga Choi representation tinatapos natin na dapat magkaroon ng isang
Krauss representation ng pagmamapa na fi pagkatapos ay ginagawa natin ang isang analogous na bagay nakakalimutan tayo ng mga Choi representation at nagtatrabaho tayo
mula sa isang arbitrary na Krauss representation at mula rito maaari tayong magtaltali na dapat mayroong Stinespring representation para sa pagmamapa na fi at sa pamamagitan ng paraan ang mga
argumento na ito ay magiging mekanikal sa ilang kahulugan na nagbibigay-daan sa atin na talagang isagawa ang mga conversion ayon sa mga arrow para sa mga partikular na channel kung gusto
natin na gawin iyon ang huling implikasyon ay magtaltali na kung mayroon tayong isang Stinespring representation para sa isang pagmamapa na fi kung gayon
ang pagmamapang iyon ay talagang isang wastong Channel at muli ay nagawa na natin iyon sa pagkakataong ito sa konteksto ng mga Stinespring
representation sa kabuuan ang apat na implikasyong ito ay nagpapakita na ang apat na bagay na ito ay lahat ay katumbas dahil maaari kang magsimula mula sa alinman sa kanila at
sundan ang mga implikasyon nang transitively upang makarating sa alinman sa iba pa magsisimula tayo sa unang implikasyon
na kung mayroon tayong channel na fi ibig sabihin ng isang linear na Mapa na palaging nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix kung gayon mayroon itong isang Choi
representation na nakakatugon sa dalawang kondisyon na natukoy natin kanina katulad ng ito ay positive semi-definite
at kung nag-trace tayo ng output na sistema makukuha natin ang identity sa input na sistema at tulad ng nabanggit ko kanina ay
natalakay na natin ang implikasyong ito sa konteksto ng mga Choi state partikular kapag hinati natin ang Choi representation ng isang channel ng n ang bilang ng
mga klasikal na estado ng input na sistema kung gayon nakakakuha tayo ng isang density Matrix at bukod dito ang reduced state ng input
sistema X para sa estado na iyon ay ang ganap na mixed state o sa ibang salita ang identity Matrix na hinati ng n ang pag-clear ng denominator ay nagbibigay sa atin ng ating
dalawang kondisyon kaya ang implikasyong ito ay medyo mabilis at madali dahil natalakay na natin
ito ngayon tingnan natin ang ikalawang implikasyon sa pagkakataong ito magsisimula tayo sa Choi representation ng isang pagmamapa na
ipinagpapalagay nating nasasapat sa dalawang kinakailangan at ang ating layunin ay makabuo ng isang Krauss representation para sa pagmamapang ito na
nakakatugon sa kinakailangang tinalakay natin dati ang implikasyong ito ay medyo mekanikal sa ilang kahulugan kakailanganin natin ang
kaunting linear algebra at pangunahin itong magreresulta sa pagmamanipula ng mga matrix at vector sa isang medyo matalinong
paraan nagsisimula ito sa assumption na ang Choi representation ay positive semi-definite na siyang una sa dalawang kinakailangan na ipinagpapalagay nating
nandoon ang konsepto ng isang positive semi-definite Matrix ay pangunahing mahalaga sa Quantum na impormasyon at hindi lamang sa konteksto ng density
matrix ito ay ganap na kritikal dito hindi natin magagawa ito nang wala ito partikular ang assumption
na ang jfi ay positive semi-definite ay nagbibigay-daan sa atin na ipahayag ito sa anyo na ipinapakita sa screen para sa ilang pagpipilian ng
mga vector na s0 hanggang S N minus isa at ilang pagpipilian ng isang positibong integer n at hayaan akong paunang itala na ang mga ito ay
hindi kinakailangang mga unit vector isang paraan na maaari nating makuha ang isang Ekspresyon tulad nito ay mula sa spectral theorem para sa positive
semi-definite na mga matrix na tinalakay sa nakaraang aralin dito ay hindi natin nakikita ang anumang eigenvalue na hayagang lumalabas tulad ng mayroon tayo sa isang spectral
decomposition ngunit tandaan na ang mga eigenvalue ng positive semi-definite na mga matrix ay palaging non-negative na tunay na mga numero at gayundin tandaan na hindi natin
hinihiling na ang mga vector na ito na S 0 hanggang S N minus isa ay mga unit vector kaya ang maaari nating gawin ay kumuha ng mga square root ng
mga eigenvalue at pararamihin ang mga ito sa mga unit eigenvector na nakukuha natin mula sa isang spectral decomposition upang makakuha ng mga
vector na s0 hanggang S N minus1 talagang hindi mahalaga para sa patunay na ito na ang mga vector na ito ay orthogonal tayo ay
makakakuha ng iyon mula sa isang spectral decomposition ngunit hindi natin gagamitin iyon dito at kung mayroon tayong ibang ekspresyon ng jfi tulad nito na hindi nagmula sa spectral
theorem kung gayon iyon ay magiging maayos din ngayon hinihiwalay natin ang bawat isa sa mga vector na ito tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen at
ito ay tulad ng gagawin natin kung ang mga vector na ito ay mga Quantum State vector ng isang pares ng mga sistema XY at tayo ay
nagsasagawa ng isang standard basis measurement sa sistemang X upang maging malinaw hindi tayo sumusukat ng anumang bagay dito isinusulat lang natin ang mga vector na ito sa anyo na ito na
palaging posible at ngayon narito ang trick tinukoy natin ang mga Krauss matrix na a0 hanggang a n minus isa sa pamamagitan ng pagputol ng K
A's mula sa harap ng mga vector na ito na s0 hanggang S N minus isa sa pamamagitan ng pag-flip sa kanila upang sila ay maging bra A's kaysa sa
K A's at ang pag-stick ng mga ito sa kanan tulad ng ipinapakita sa equation sa screen isang paraan upang isipin
ito ay karaniwang tinitiklop natin ang mga vector na ito upang mabuo ang mga matrix kaya kung itatambak natin ang mga Column ng AK sa isa't isa makukuha natin
muli ang s kaya ang mga matrix na ito ay may eksaktong parehong mga entry bilang ang kaukulang mga vector ngunit na-rearrange natin lamang ang
mga entry nang iba upang makakuha ng mga matrix ngunit maaari rin nating isipin ang mga matrix na ito nang puro simboliko sa mga tuntunin ng direct notation
tulad ng nakasulat dito at ngayon sa puntong ito mayroong isang halata na tanong bakit dapat itong gumana huwag tayong masyadong mapigilan
kung bakit ito gumagana subukan na lang nating i-verify na ito ay gumagana upang gawin ito tukuyin natin ang isang bagong pagmamapa na ang pagmamapa ay tinukoy ng
mga matrix na ito kung saan itinuturing natin ang mga ito bilang mga Krauss matrix kung ano ang maaari nating gawin ngayon ay kwentahin ang Choi representation ng
bagong pagmamapang ito at makikita natin na ito ay katumbas ng Choi representation ng pagmamapang F na sinimulan natin at
dahil ang mga Choi representation ay tapat nangangahulugan ito na ang dalawang pagmamapa ay talagang katumbas hindi ko dadaanan ang algebra sa video na ito maaari
mong i-verify iyon mismo ito ay medyo mekanikal at magandang pagsasanay at lahat ng kailangan mo para doon ay nasa
screen dito hindi pa natin nasabi ang anuman tungkol sa dalawang ikalawang kondisyon sa dalawang kahon ngunit
lumalabas na sila ay katumbas at isang paraan upang maitatag iyon ay i-verify ang equation na ipinapakita dito sa ibaba ng
screen ang titik na T dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay tumutukoy sa Matrix transposition na maaari mong alternatibong isipin bilang ang
linear na pagmamapa na ginagawang k a bra B ang k b bra a at ito ay isang bagay lang na kailangan upang gumana ang formula kaya sa
buod tiyak na may kailangan na algebra para sa implikasyong ito ngunit tulad ng sinabi ko ito ay lahat ay medyo mekanikal
karaniwang index gymnastics tulad ng tinutukoy ng ilang tao sa ganitong uri ng bagay ngunit kung magtrabaho ka dito at bibigyan mo ang iyong utak ng pagkakataon na i-digest ito maaari kang makarating
na may mas malalim na pag-unawa kung paano ang mga Choi representation at Krauss representation ay nauugnay ang ikatlong implikasyon ay nagpapahintulot sa atin
na pumunta mula sa isang Krauss representation ng isang pagmamapa na fi kung saan ang karaniwang kondisyon ay nandoon patungo sa isang Stinespring representation ang isang ito ay medyo
katulad sa diwa ng nakaraang implikasyon sa kahulugan na ito ay mekanikal at maaaring makita at ma-verify sa puro algebraic na mga termino ang
ideya ay talagang medyo simple kung ano ang maaari nating gawin ay ang kumuha ng ating mga Krauss matrix at bumuo ng bahagi ng isang mas malaking matrix sa pamamagitan ng pag-stack
ng mga ito sa isa't isa tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen kapag napuno na ito ay magbibigay sa atin ng unitary Matrix U para sa isang
Stinespring representation ang mga unitary matrix ay dapat na mga square matrix kaya kakailanganin nating punan ang maraming natitirang
column hangga't kailangan upang gawin iyon ngunit hindi talaga gagawa ng pagkakaiba kung ano sila basta nakakakuha tayo ng isang unitary
Matrix kung sandali nating iiwanan ang pag-aalala na ang U ay unitary at tututukan lamang ang linear na pagmamapa na tinukoy ng
Stinespring representation na nakukuha natin mula sa Matrix U kung gayon ang nahanap natin ay ang pagmamapa ay katumbas ng
orihinal na pagmamapa na fi na tinukoy ng Krauss representation na sinimulan natin iyon ay isa pang bahagi ng patunay na hindi ko dadaanan sa video na ito maaari
mong mahanap ang mga detalye sa nakasulat na nilalaman para sa araling ito ngunit maaari ka ring pumili na gumugol ng oras at gawin ito para sa iyong sarili tandaan lang
tulad ng karaniwan para sa serye na gumagamit tayo ng kubit ordering convention upang bigyang-kahulugan ang diagram kaya ang w at G ay
tutugma sa mga tensor factor sa kaliwang bahagi sa mga equation at sa pamamagitan ng paraan kung gagawin mo ito
mahahanap mo na dahil mayroon tayong k0o bra zero bilang tensor Factor sa kaliwang bahagi sa equation
ang kailangan nating i-verify ay ang tanging bahagi ng U na may kaugnayan ay ang bahagi na ibinibigay ng mga Krauss matrix kaya basta punuin natin ang
mga column ng U sa paraang ginagawa nitong unitary kung gayon maayos tayo ngunit siyempre nangangailangan ito na ang mga column na nabuo ng a0 hanggang a n minus
isa kapag itinambak natin ang mga ito sa isa't isa ay orthonormal at dito pumapasok ang kondisyon na inilalagay natin sa mga Krauss representation
at ito nga ay tumpak na katumbas ng pagiging orthonormal ng mga column ang mga kaugnay na relasyon sa matematika na kailangan upang iguhit ang
konklusyong ito ay ipinapakita sa ibaba ng screen kaya sige at i-pause at i-verify kung pipiliin mo o muli
kumonsulta sa nakasulat na nilalaman para sa karagdagang mga detalye sa maikling salita kung ano ang nangyayari dito sa parehong implikasyong ito at sa
nakaraang isa ay ang naglalarawan tayo ng parehong matematika na mga operasyon sa iba't ibang ngunit katumbas na mga paraan ang
Beating Heart ng lahat ng ito sa esensya ay matrix multiplikasyon ang ika-apat at huling implikasyon ay nagtatatag na kung mayroon tayong isang
Stinespring representation para sa ilang pagmamapa kung gayon ang pagmamapang iyon ay talagang isang wastong Channel at tulad ng ipinahiwatig ko
kanina ay natalakay na natin ang implikasyong ito noong tinalakay natin ang mga Stinespring representation sa buod at sa
bahagyang magkaibang mga termino ang pagpapakilala ng isang inisyalisadong workspace system ay isang wastong Channel iyon ay dahil ang pag-tensor ng isang naayos na
density Matrix sa isang ibinigay na density Matrix ay palaging nagbibigay sa atin ng isang density Matrix at ito ay isang linear na pagmamapa dahil sa bilinearity
ng mga tensor product ang mga unitary na operasyon ay palaging mga wastong channel tulad ng tinalakay ko kanina sa aralin ang pag-trace out ng isang sistema ay isang wastong Channel dahil ang
partial trace ay isang linear na pagmamapa na palaging nagbabago ng mga density matrix sa mga density matrix at sa wakas ang mga composition ng
mga channel ay palaging mga channel na medyo simple ngunit tiyak na sulit na obserbahan sa sarili nito at sa mga
apat na implikasyong tinalakay natin naitatag na natin ang katumbasan ng ating tatlong representasyon ng Channel kasama ang
orihinal na kahulugan ng isang channel partikular nagsimula tayo sa kahulugan ng isang channel nakita natin kung paano ang kahulugang iyon ay nagpapahiwatig na ang Choi
representation nito ay kinakailangang nakakatugon sa dalawang pangunahing kondisyon pagkatapos nakita natin kung paano ang mga kondisyong iyon ay nagbibigay-daan sa atin na makahanap ng isang Krauss representation na sa turn
ay nagbibigay-daan sa atin na makahanap ng isang Stinespring representation at sa wakas nakita natin na ang pagkakaroon ng isang Stinespring representation ay nagpapakita na talagang mayroon tayong
wastong channel siyempre mayroong mga teknikal na detalye doon at hindi ito kinakailangang simple lalo na
kapag nakikita mo ito sa unang pagkakataon ngunit kung ano ang kawili-wili at kapansin-pansin dito ay ang mga implikasyong ito ay naka-set up sa isang paraan na talagang
ginagawa ang mga bagay na kasing madali hangga't maaari at sa matematika hindi ka dapat kailanman makaramdam ng kahihiyan sa pagsunod sa madaling paraan para sa
halimbawa hindi malinaw na ang bawat channel ay may isang Stinespring representation o isang Krauss representation
ngunit medyo madaling tapusin na ang Choi representation ng bawat channel ay nakakatugon sa dalawang kondisyon na ating iniugnay dito at
nagbibigay-daan ito sa atin na sumunod sa isang higit o kulang na algebraic na landas patungo sa dalawa pang representasyon sa katulad na paraan ang
huling implikasyon mula sa isang Stinespring representation pabalik sa kahulugan ay medyo simple rin at
nagbibigay-daan sa atin na tapusin na nakakakuha lamang tayo ng mga channel at walang iba pang mga pagmamapa mula sa mga Choi representation ipinagpapalagay na ang
kinakailangang mga kondisyon ay natutugunan at tulad ng binanggit ko dati ang paraan ng ating pag-aargumento ng mga implikasyong ito ay sapat na mekanikal upang madali tayong mag-convert
sa pagitan ng mga representasyon at kung babalik ka sa ilang mga halimbawa na tinalakay natin kanina sa aralin mahahanap mo na ito ay talagang posible na
mag-convert sa pagitan ng mga representasyon minsan nang medyo madali at direkta at iyon ay ang katapusan ng
aralin na tungkol sa mga channel tinalakay natin kung ano ang mga ito at tiningnan natin ang ilang pangunahing halimbawa tinalakay natin ang tatlong paraan na maaaring
katawanin ang mga channel at sumisid tayo sa ilang teknikal na detalye na nagtatatag ng katumbasan ng mga representasyong ito
umaasa akong sasama ka sa susunod na aralin na tungkol sa mga sukat sa pangkalahatang pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon paalam hanggang sa susunod